all right Eureka and Jean-Claude
you guys have strip clubs
male strip shows in Vegas and L.A
correct how'd you get into that
oh uh actually through production
through production we did a movie called
Chocolate City took off
um and then we did a television show
with Lifetime right
uh with Vivica Fox Tyson Beckford and
then we decided to take it on the road
and this has become a popular thing it
is hugely popular it's not something I
ever thought I was ever going to end up
doing
um I thought I'd be a film producer for
the rest of my life
um but yeah it's taken on a life of his
own we see hundreds of women a weekend
and it's just insane pure Mayhem
so Jean-Claude your clubs are open to
everyone but they're mainly
African-American is that right yeah yeah
mainly all of our dancers are are
African-American or black men
um and our customers are primarily uh
black women
we get about maybe
maybe 15 other
um Asian Pacific Islanders white but
mainly
um black women and how does a black Club
a black strip club differ than a than a
white one do you think
oh it's it's a huge difference it's it's
a huge difference
um just a huge just another culture the
culture is so different right yeah I
mean when we first started this
um you know it was a world that I wasn't
even familiar with I I'd never I don't
even go to female strip clubs so I don't
I don't I didn't know that world existed
um until Magic Mike came out and a good
friend of mine called me up over at one
of the studios and he said hey look we
know you're into black filmmaking and
you may go what about doing a black
version of Magic Mike I said well
actually I don't know anything about the
world I'm not really particularly
interested
um and then the movie comes out
Magic Mike and it's huge it's it's it's
tremendous and you know as a filmmaker I
immediately thought okay let's let's
start exploring this so a friend of mine
out here in Los Angeles took me to some
underground uh black male strip shows in
the hood
and when I walked in there
it was I mean it was it was in a very
dangerous neighborhood but but
the the the culture was so palpable it
was these these black women some were
doctors lawyers uh nurses nurses School
teachers I it but they came some were in
the VIP section with uh uh uh suitcases
with money literally for for these guys
but what I found fascinating about the
world was
the the sense of empowerment that these
women had that I'd never seen before in
a group of black women
um and that immediately struck me it was
their world they controlled it they they
were the architects of and the designers
of what was happening and their power
you felt it and me having grown around
up you know I've got three sisters and a
mom obviously
um you know black women
um
uh tend to be as far as their sexuality
a public display of their sexuality tend
to be more tempered
um they grow up with sort of very strict
uh judeo-christian
morality and so
um
this exhibition this this this display
outwardly display of uh
sexual whatever you want to call it
interest Freedom expression was what
really caught me I said I gotta make a
movie I gotta do this and so we went
back sat down we scripted we put a
script together and
um I got a friend of mine who finances a
lot of my movies and he's like he says
like you know how much would it cost to
make this movie I mean Magic Mike was
like I don't know what it was 40 million
50 million and I was like you give me
two million bucks I'll make a good movie
so I gave me the money I went out made
the movie we sold it before I was done
filming to Paramount for five and a half
million bucks so it's always good as an
independent filmmaker to be able to make
a movie and then sell it before you you
don't have to go around shopping it so
anyway uh they bought the movie movie
comes out takes off it's got some really
hot black guys in it Tyson Beckford
Michael Jai White and some really big
big sexy guys
um
and then um and then we decided we're
going to create a live version of of it
and put it at some clubs here in in La
we did it there were lines literally I
mean we we were just I mean the owner of
the club came to me and said excuse me
sir we we you told us 300 people it's
three thousand oh he said he told us
like less than 100 people he was upset
that we had more of them there's 3 000
people out there lines all the way
around the block and um and uh we knew
we had something that we had tapped into
something and um then we decided uh do a
Southern California tours we sold out
and eventually went to Vegas and when we
got to Vegas which had up to that point
they had uh uh Magic Mike they had a
live show Thunder from Down Under
Chippendales they had you know those
shows but they were all white
predominantly white shows uh to
celebrate bachelorettes and you know
different things and um
uh we called up one of the biggest
Brokers out there and said hey we've got
a show
um we'd love to bring it out here uh
will you guys represent us and sell
tickets and they were like no we're not
gonna we're not we're not interested
there isn't a market for this I'm like
trust me there's a market for this
there's hundreds of hundreds and
thousands of black women that come to
Vegas every year nowhere to go there's
nowhere to go so we we uh we push them
and eventually they uh uh uh uh took us
on and started selling tickets we sold
out literally the first month uh that
were out there we sold out every show
and they finally called us back in the
office and said look we didn't know we
did not know that uh there was such a
hunger for this and and that is really
what what our show is it's it's a place
where black women predominantly come to
express themselves feel free have a
great time
um uh uh comrade among each other uh and
um
we we see it almost as I'd say this to
her every night uh we see it almost like
it's a clinic uh where uh because of the
the black women
and and you know there's a whole
tradition whole history of uh you know
uh black women being sexually exploited
black women uh whether you're traced
that all the way back to slavery and
being used as almost sexual uh cattle uh
to reproduce and create more slaves Etc
that
um their sexuality has been for lack of
a better word suppressed in a lot of
ways and so
um church is really pushed really hard
in the black black home and
um
and so we now see women ages 18. to 95
that come and it is such a beautiful
thing to see because
you know how much they've had to
overcome
to open up their minds to be here and so
we celebrate with them and and the guys
make them feel uh beautiful and make
them feel sexy and make them feel worthy
um and for the men on the men's side
um
a lot of uh you know we're also burdened
as black men with some of those those uh
sexual innuendos and sexual shackles
um and
it is a they are celebrated it is a
place where black men their sexuality is
no longer considered Taboo it's no
longer something that's icky it doesn't
come across aggressive scary
you know just all of those all the
stigmas right yeah right Eureka what is
it about
the African-American community that
makes this so
popular
I mean are the other women repressed as
Sean Claude was kind of indicating I do
think we are our uh repressed to an
extent
um and we're often
women in general are often pinned
against each other you know who looks
better who's dating this guy who's who's
got their hair done or you know just
there's always some sort of we're always
pinned against each other and in in the
Blackmagic life space whenever you enter
that theater is just
it's almost as if you just found a bunch
of girlfriends or sisters long lost
sisters that you never knew there was a
system you know there is a Sisterhood
that's built there and I think that's
really what has made the show so popular
made our club so popular
um and of course the interaction with
the guys the way that men carry
themselves because you know like
chocolate said we had went to a couple
of strip clubs when we were in
pre-production for Chocolate City
and
strip clubs
[Music]
there can be a dark out there's a little
bit of a dark element there and we
worked really hard to sort of remove
that from our show so to keep it as fun
as sexy and
pop and it's sort of mainstream we've
we've really helped make
the sexy black man mainstream a little
bit when it comes to the Vegas stage
um and I think that's what I think
that's what it's been I think the fact
that we've been pinned against each
other
and and just to be able to go somewhere
and just be free and have fun not be
judged and and freely be able to post it
on social media who gets to do that I
think that's really what has changed our
space right yeah
tell me about the the men that you
look for to get up on stage so
you know when we first got into this
world
um we were blind in terms of how we were
navigating it because we'd never done it
before and um uh our eyes quickly opened
to the reality that this could be a very
edgy could be a very dangerous
environment
um why principally a lot of the guys are
dancers or either felons ex-felons or
either
um
uh drug drug users
um you know extremely rough childhood or
gang members uh those are the guys that
typically I don't know about the white
world but definitely in the black male
review space those are the men who tend
to gravitate towards that form of
employment largely because there are no
other opportunities open to them right
they have rap sheets say whatever you
know
um so
I had to navigate through that we had to
navigate through it
um you know I'm from Brooklyn so there
is an element of me that that is you
could say
street whatever but I'm able to detect
where there could be potential danger
where you know the type of people I want
to associate myself with and so when we
were putting this show together there
was a very very keen eye uh to
extracting those elements that we did
not that was not consistent with a
mainstream type of show right because 95
percent of the people that come see our
show especially in Vegas are Taurus and
they're from everywhere they're from all
across the country and there's a median
age the median age of ladies that attend
black male strip shows is like 35. so
these are mature women and they expect
to come in a place that is safe A place
where they can celebrate without you
know feeling
you know any kind of
predatory Vibes yeah predatory Vibes or
elements of danger so we we took a lot
of time to make sure that we we put
together a show that was fun and a safe
environment that sounds great
I'm sure
that Vegas is a perfect market for what
you're doing
yeah I don't think it gets any better
than Vegas right now it doesn't get any
better than Vegas there's literally
everyone sort of that comes through that
door every type of woman comes through
that door short tall skinny overweight
you know we sick cancer uh um patients
yeah cancer survivors it's just
literally we get um army women women who
are in the military we get doctors uh
just this past Sunday you had a two
sheriffs in there I don't know two
shirts you know yeah yeah it's it's it's
it's a it's an environment that again
we're starting to see it open up women
are starting to express themselves more
sexually
um and when I say more sexually it's not
I don't mean you know women are more uh
sexual I mean they are they're opening
up their minds to expressing their
desire to appreciate the male physique
the male uh and the guy strips down to
some briefs or something like that right
well yeah yeah right
yeah we don't do the g strings in our
show our show goes as far as boxers and
even that is like one set for the we
again we try to keep it
um
um as PG-13 as you can because then you
have a wider audience
larger audience pool if you make it
where guys are swinging their penis like
like it's you know yeah it becomes a
little bit of a of a challenge and that
there's already a place for that there's
tons of regular strip clubs that do that
all night we don't need to yeah our show
is pretty much a lot of it is is
choreographed and and that was a
challenge you know you're getting guys
from the hood guys from the streets to
learn dance moves and it's you know it's
like literally working with toddlers
it's like two left feet two left legs
you know it's it's still a struggle
during weekly rehearsals and that's the
other thing too you know we've created
an environment you know again I you know
I spoke to and Eureka spoke to how the
women
um
uh the value of this to to the women for
the men I can't tell you it is it is
we've watched these men literally grow
and develop as mature citizens from you
know
even something as simple as hey we've
got we we've got a meeting today at four
o'clock and trying to get all these guys
who are used to just very loose
schedules and not you know they're not
regimented that way and they're not
programmed that way
um and so it's sort of a re-education in
a lot of ways and getting these black
men who otherwise and I'd like to
believe maybe I'm blowing too much smoke
up my own ass but I'd like to believe
that our show has helped save some lives
um no it has
yeah that's great that's great what are
the names of your clubs
Chocolate City
um and uh Blackmagic live these are both
in Vegas one's here in La at the Savoy
we do it every uh Thursday and Friday
nights and in Las Vegas uh black magic
lives Blackmagic live Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday Monday yeah that's
whether that's where the real
uh uh money is yeah excellent
Eureka Jean-Claude thank you so much for
for telling us about these interesting
clubs that we never knew about yeah and
uh
hope you guys have a fun weekend yeah
next time you're in Vegas come on
through maybe we'll put you on oh yeah
men are allowed too men are
[Music]
we get all the time couples come in I
mean I tell people all the time you know
when I was younger uh
I used to go to you know now it's all
internet based but I used to go to clubs
you know meet women you know you go to
the bar and hey you want me to get a
drink blah blah
um if I knew about male review shows
back then I'd never go to a club I'd go
to a male review shop I mean it's
literally 300 women there yeah all hot
and bothered hitting on everything
testosterone walking back you know our
waiter gets hit on more than anybody
that has a security guard everyone
everyone
anyone can get it at that moment it's so
funny you're just sharing a little fun
for everybody yeah that's right that's
right yeah it's a lot of fun it's a lot
of fun to see people just let loose have
fun without getting into trouble
afterwards normally you go out you get
drunk you do something outlandish and
you're in trouble the next morning you
know you come over here to our show and
it's just you wake up with a clean slate
you're good you're good when you wake up
no regrets
excellent all right Eureka thank you so
much thank you thank you thank you